mais tirer une boule et le numéro qui va
s'afficher pas que je vais tirer de ces
de bourges bien mélange de saillé là
viendra mettre cette perruque et prendra
la place de kelly le biais gant de fer
comme kelly alors à touille ça on a fait
longtemps que nous dit la thérapie
[Applaudissements]
le numéro le numéro 120
à l'arrivée ou non
alors n'attendez comment quand vous avez
vous car à chiara vous venez d'où car à
part dont âgées et moi cette page est
venue des fruits noah mais il faut que
je fasse gaffe qu'elle fait dans la vie
en classe oui et le bac
qu'est ce que vous foutez là c'est donc
sebastian seulement le bac elle va rater
ça se passe à l'école a pu très bien
bc je pense et je vous dit quelque chose
comme ça va venir kobe dans l'avancement
france avait-elle et vous dit quelque
chose
vous connaissez mais vous savez quoi je
crois que mais non par le plus grand des
hasards
je viens de tirer la boule de la meute
de mustapha aller vite et vous mettez
moi en place c'est bizarre ces tournées
fait des bonds place bon en même temps
non
la période ça va les cheveux fait voir
comme senna va avoir chaud la pauvre ma
grave c'est des extensions c'est pas mal
assez c'est pas mal ça les bd bourg
place le remplace
n'hésitez pas allez une petite sonnette
lier mon portrait bim bim
alors ça c est 100 m ça c'est incroyable
mais vous n'avez pas l'air sûre non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
1-1 m bull pour prouver que c'est pas
tout le samba surtout vous vous en
souviendrez quand on est grillé en fait
oui peut voir à
[Applaudissements]
tara
j'ai fait j'ai fait comme cyril j'ai
changé les règles on changera tout à
l'heure à les rhénans un seul instant
une séquence triche dans l'émission